one of the things that you mentioned
earlier though was the walls though so I
wanted to go back to the walls like yeah
if if you want to be with a guy if you
want to be building something with a guy
something authentic I think I heard you
say something about authenticity earlier
why would you put up walls to stop him
from connecting with
you
um I think it's like I don't know it's
like a power and control cycle because
I've been trapped on that before I'd say
it's like a lot of like love bombing
like pretty stuff in the beginning and
then what I'm I'm scared about is like
when things get hard like like nobody
nobody wants to
see like someone it's like there's
there's no effort in humanity anymore
like if if nothing's picture perfect if
nothing's just like like your profile
like it's just you can't feel if you do
you're weak and I think guys see that
like as a female it's like oh we it's
too much to handle we're just kind of
going to push that aside like move on to
the next thing or just whatever guys do
now and then girls as like I think as
like empathetic or especially sensitive
ones um I think what we
do um preventively is just like put a
huge wall up like before you can get
hurt you hurt them
first her trauma is her wall
yeah my op on this oh go ahead what do
you think your trauma
is who's are you asking Caitlyn Caitlyn
yeah oh I know what my trauma is but I'm
not gonna say that on a podcast okay and
my opinion is too is that having the
walls ultimately is kind of like
what's uh and I don't mean it in any you
know offense of anything but it's kind
of the walls that's kind of not allowing
you to actually hone in the details of
the man that you you actually really
truly desire and it's going to stop you
from finding him I know we love the
narrative and the roric that he's just
going to find me one day but from my
dating experience and what I've learned
just and including my trauma as well is
that um that's it's not how it's ever
going to work um not only you got a man
that's going to put in the effort if
he's intentional but if you're if the
woman's intentional then it's actually
on her too as well to put in the amount
of time effort resources investment as
well but she I mean and it's going to be
different to where you know he's doing
it as a man she's doing it as as uh as a
woman and the another narrative that
gets thrown around a lot is that you
know says know your
worth um that you know uh he's not
worthy of you that happens all the time
I see that a lot and my cringe factor
with that is like okay well then what is
the worth and what has this woman done
to earn it because I've learned that
even as easy as days it is with my
husband every day is still relationship
laundry such as making sure it's all
work it and it's just as simple as you
know making sure I you know I slap his
cute when I walk past him giv the
affection that he does the same for me
um but and then also wanting to take on
conflicts and the tough times head on
together um and that's the other thing
too that I've noticed is that a lot of
people shy away from conflict
and it's just gonna that's the other
thing too it's just G to happen it's um
I mean we have to have the tough
conversations completely I mean six
months into our dating he said it's like
okay you know you understand I have MS
uh you either need a walk or you're
committed to this and and
um I mean so that and then the other
thing too I noticed in the beginning of
dating too is that um kind of like
putting on kind of like the show trying
to impress is because there hasn't been
any time to observe anybody under duress
um or in Conflict to really see their
true character that's really where in my
opinion true character can really come
out is is during conflict during those
tough
conversations and without people wanting
to deal with it or just don't have any
conflict resol ution um that's where
just everything is just falling
apart um and also not getting over hurts
trauma kind of like always being fearful
that's going to happen again is also
holding back a lot of people um the
other thing that's holding back a lot of
people too is coming on with the face a
lot of people are not putting their self
forward to where to what's going to be
sustainable and what's going to
maintain um theoretically a a healthy
relationship you know build upon it
and then being able to keep it to keep
it healthy and keep it going and
maintain and sustain um I don't think
many people go for the sustaining part
at all with respects to the trauma part
of where you know we get to and I've
seen us arrive at this before and I'm
going to I'm going to give you the
resentment and guilt
speech
um if you guys have watched the entire
series you know you know what I'm going
to talk about here I think we were
talking to Kelly about this one was name
if I'm not mistaken
but in life we we carry baggage around
in the form
of emotions that we project outwardly
and inwardly the guilt component is what
we project on ourselves the resentment
is what we is what we project in other
people right I feel guilty because of
insert reasons I feel resentful because
of these reasons because these things
happened to me a lot of the time not not
for me you know not not for the benefit
of me not for the growth of me but but
to me and it's like we now collect
these I don't want to call them Awards
but we but if you can picture a stack of
clay bricks and a Sharpie marker in your
hand and just writing on each brick when
it comes to like the resentment uh you
know he did this to me so and so did
that and then you sort of collect these
things and you put them in a big burlap
bag and you have all these heavy bricks
that you carry around over your shoulder
only they're invisible and nobody sees
them and they're just resentment and
guilt resentment and guilt resentment
and guilt and then it prevents you from
dealing with guys it prevents you from
getting past certain things it prevents
you from letting people in and then you
make up these stories and you ego
invests in these stories like well he'll
just show up or I'll manifest him or as
long as he has this OR b or the other
thing but there's underlying things
beneath that and this entire bag of
bricks that you know we collect for
ourselves you know with the resentment
and guilt labeled on them you just put
it down and you walk away from it and
it's really easy to say and to describe
what goes on with these with these
little bitter pieces of like trauma that
sort of Stack upon each other and you
sometimes you take these bricks and you
build walls with them too SLA them
together like you're a Mason and you
build walls and you keep people out of
your life sort of thing um and then the
thing that I always go to when people do
stuff like that is the question well
how's that working out for
you I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clips from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out